I'm joined today by Charles durbur who's
a public sociologist and author of the
book welcome to the revolution
universalizing resistance for social
justice and democracy in perilous times
could not be more timely and I think
maybe a good place to start is I'm super
interested in this idea of
universalizing resistance in activism
what do you mean by that
yeah well it is the central idea of the
book and what I mean basically is that
let me let me give an example I think
after the 60s we took three progressive
universalizing periods on the left and
Trump is actually a very good example of
universal on the right so let me start
with an example and then maybe I can get
the concept of it clear to you so Trump
is a universal Iser in the following
sense one he brought together a identity
politics which is has to do with you
know America first and being in America
and being proud and being great about
the lineage of American culture and
nation hood with an up class politics
which is sort of his economic
nationalism and arguing that the working
class really needed to come together and
struggle for its rightful place in the
economy and that meant moving from a
global economy run by sort of liberal
elite corporate and otherwise and and
become nationalist in all forms that's
so the bringing together the uniting of
different kinds of movements into one
kind of disruptive challenge to the
overall political and economic system is
one key dimension of universalizing
resistance the second is that he came
from sort of outside a party of at a
democratic four course for a long time
and he he just kind of parachuted into
the Republican Party and linked all
these right way
movements evangelicals the libertarians
you know gun advocates and so forth
with very strange bedfellows into our
corporate elite who often do a lot of
harm to people working people who became
his base but he was able to sort of you
know we used to call to unite United
Front he was able to bring together
Street movements with a mainstream party
and pull them together that is
universalized them into again into a
coherent force for for dramatic systemic
disruption and change this is
fascinating on in a few ways I mean one
of them as you mentioned the sort of
identity politics that that Donald Trump
employed over the last several years
you've seen by and large the right
criticize at the left for their use of
identity politics and I as someone who
identifies with the left I've been
critical of some particular applications
of identity politics but that doesn't
mean that the right doesn't utilize
identity politics as well I mean I think
the alt-right movement which is critical
of left-wing identity politics is
actually really an identity movement
sort of at its core so I think that
you're pointing out something which is
very interesting which is it's not that
the right doesn't do identity politics
they do it in a different way than the
left at least recently is that fair I
think it's fair it's really important
actually that identity politics has been
identified with liberals on the Left and
it's by your right and I'm running on
actually a new book I mean much of this
book focuses on Trump's identity
politics but because it is very
important and not spoken about enough
but in this book I spoke is especially
on progressive politics and my argument
my universalizing there in this book
welcoming welcome to the revolution
universalizing resistance I'm mainly
focusing on the whole history and
current state of the left which has
since the late 60s essentially become a
siloed movement you know people each
part of the movement and a lot of this
is identity movements mainly race you
know anti-racist movement anti-sexist
movements gay right ov and so forth very
important
movement but fragmented and not brought
together and and also disconnected from
what used to be for example in the New
Deal in the populist period of the
Gilded Age back in the 1890s and in the
60s that identity politics was tied to a
broad anti-systemic fairly well
coordinated class politics you know if
historically the Left had been very
concerned about economic justice and
class struggle and class politics and
ever since the six-piece the left has
morphed from until very recently I
killed Bernie Sanders I'm a 2016
election which we should get through but
from basically the end of the 60s when
white student males who are running our
students for a Democratic Society and
the anti-war movement and you know the
the civil rights movement so forth there
were males often white who were in
control and women and people of color
recognized that they were being
marginalized by these movements and and
felt they had needed to start their own
movements which have been incredibly
powerful I'm sorry let's talk about that
in a little more detail before we move
on because you're identifying something
that I'm hearing is similar to what I've
identified in terms of thinking about
identity politics on the left over the
last 50 years which is that the version
of identity politics that we've
increasingly seen on the left over the
last you know we could say five eight or
ten years has been in identity politics
where individually we are talking about
all important and relevant identity
movements but they've not been
universalized in a way that has been a
successful in winning elections and very
often I'm criticized when I point to the
60s and the sort of more economic
populist message of economic justice and
I will get emails from people who say
David that's too simplistic it's not
just economic populism or these
fragmented identity politics movements
but I'm often criticized for that point
of view can you talk a little bit more
about that shift that you've seen that
that is a really big issue and in you
know in the book is involves I've
written it but I've included a little
from very prominent and important
activists and this has become a you know
from Noam Chomsky to people in black
lives matter and Ferguson and this issue
just raised it is come up over and over
again are you when you talk about
universalizing basically trying to go
back to a kind of white male politics
which which doesn't give enough
significance to the importance of race
and gender in each nation and I think
I've been very clear and I think I think
these people have collaborated with me
we're getting out this book is like a
movement because so many different parts
of the movement have contributed to it
are helping helping me bring it out to
the world what I'm arguing it is that
one we need to resurrect an economic
justice class politics on the left
because ever since really the the new
right and Reagan who really you know
destroyed unions and really crushed the
sort of class politics were left and
then the Clintons coming along in the
90s and basically doing a third way
centrist politics which was basically a
decisive repudiation of the New Deal
which really was an economic justice
movement we've seen the Left transform
into this sort of grab bag collection of
fragmented siloed identity politics now
I'm not trying to critique them in the
sense of saying they should go away or
anything like that particularly under
Trump these groups are incredibly
vulnerable they're always been
incredibly vulnerable and we need them
and they achieved an enormous important
success but when we disassociate these
identity movements on the left from one
a clamor unifying class politics which
you know the identity politics needs a
class politics with you if you run for
example you have women who argued to
break the glass ceiling and they're just
accepting the idea of not going after
the structure of the corporation more
broadly but just getting women like like
you know miss Sanders that
at Facebook well in her book leaning in
the idea feminism
it wasn't a critique of you know the
corporate system at all it was an
argument of women should lean in and
embrace capitalism and embrace the whole
economic system well that's good for
privileged white women but it's not good
for the majority of women who are people
of color or working you know single moms
or working-class women who have and the
same is true for blacks who are being
left behind further even as these
identity movements have done very very
important work in breaking through
during kind of you know terrible
discrimination so my argument is that we
need this universalizing which will both
help and strengthen the identity
movements we resurrect the intensity and
power of all the periods in American
history where economic justice and class
politics have been driving forces where
the left has been successful and also
helped to build a more unifying message
that can connect the left and this is
also a controversial thing with the
Democratic Party as well as with the
movement on the street much as Trump did
he brought you know all these very
intense right-wing movements into the
Republican Party and basically took it
over so that's really the essence of
what I'm arguing for in the book that
it's not an argument against identity
politics I think it's a false thing to
sort of say well either you're either in
economic justice movement or oh but
these are all intertwined you know you
can't solve racism and the problems of
people of color without dealing with
poverty and nature of our capitalist
system a nature of the war system and so
forth and I'll give you another example
David
well let us there if we can Charles just
so that I think this is a good place and
then we can pick up the conversation in
this exact spot I'll remind you we've
been speaking with Charles durbur who's
author of the book welcome to the
revolution universalizing resistance for
social justice and democracy in perilous
times and we'll continue our
conversation with him in this exact spot
we're continuing our conversation today
with Charles durbur who's a public
sociologist and also author of the book
welcome to the revolution universalizing
resist
for social justice and democracy in
perilous times I'd love to talk a little
bit to sort of continue the conversation
that that we paused in part one about
where you see the actual next steps for
the Democratic Party and you alluded to
this a little bit at the end of part one
of the interview this idea of the
progressive movement working within the
Democratic Party and this is actually
something of quite a bit of both
controversy and significance because
we've seen a very centrist Democratic
Party what I call corporate Democrats
now make up a pretty significant portion
of the Democratic Party and yet on most
issues we've seen the United States move
to the left whether it's abortion or
health care or LGBT rights or whatever
the case may be so what do you see is
the most effective way for progressives
to have their political desires heard
and most importantly made policy if that
is possible well this is a really
critical and very contentious issue
David on the left and I'm not arguing
that the left I think the left needs to
be in a constant dance with the
Democratic Party it can't put all its
eggs in the party but it can't as it has
often as many people already can't
ignore the Democratic Party in the three
historical periods where we've seen
universalizing parties politics on the
progressive side which have really made
a difference the Gilded Age the populist
parties the New Deal and in the 60s
there was this dance I mean in other
words the movements have penetrated the
party and you see now with you know this
came out very clearly in 2016 race when
in the conflict between Hillary Clinton
and Bernie Sanders Sanders was kind of a
voice of the movement he saw himself
that way you know he called himself a
quote Democratic Socialist which was a
major contribution because you know
after that he first said that in a
debate the most googled word in America
that day was socialism will be need a
conversation about capitalism of
socialism
that's not being heard in the mainstream
or in the mainstream parties it's almost
traitorous in in the mainstream
discourse to talk about something wrong
with capitalism as a system or something
good about democratic socialism Sanders
began to pull the Democratic Party and
the whole country in a different
direction this is critically important
we need this conversation and the
movements have always they're always
going to be pushing from the outside to
get the party to move more in that
direction but the movement the party
will never be enough but to abandon it
is to abandon your ability to ever
really get the kind of policy and the
kind of transformative change that the
movements are looking for so I think
Sanders is a really good example after
2016 as you know there is a legacy of
Sanders supporters which is you know the
organization our revolution it's got
their chapters all over the country
working on the health care issue working
on economic justice and minimum wage
issues and so forth and you know there's
a there's a struggle going on in the
Democratic Party today which is largely
been obscured because there's so much
focus on the polarization that Trump is
created in the Republican Party but that
that was productive in moving the
Republican Party along during the
campaign and it's pretty good it's very
important to the Democrats now and so I
think that the movements have to play a
very strategic game in which there and
this is happening now which are running
for local office in towns from Seattle
to Brooklyn on all over the country
you're seeing these really movement
based progressive people penetrating
into the Democrat Party running for
office and so forth but at the same time
they're what movements always have to be
there in communities they're operating
globally online offline in the streets
for much more progressive transformative
politics than the democratic party maybe
even Bernie Sanders is prepared to do at
this point so my argument is that you
you really strongly need to see a kind
of universalizing dance between the
movements on the streets and the
political parties I want to give you one
one clear example of this in the United
Front idea in Germany when when fascism
came into power you had a lot of Weimar
Germany which was German at the German
Republic in the 20s it had very strong
gay feminist experimental cultural
movement that we would call identity
politics today and it had some fairly
strong liberal and left politics the
Social Democratic Party that was running
Germany and by Maher for a while and
kind of insane Communist Party that was
very under the influence of stone
well Hitler came into power because the
movements remained separate from the
social democratic and socialist parties
and remained fragmented from each other
and so you didn't get the United Front
whereas the far right which chiller was
one of many car wreck people began to
coordinate with the German aristocracy
at the time and create a united front
with corporate and aristocratic German
elites who had run Germany before for
the by my republic and and so it's just
we're in a period that a lot of people
recognize is authoritarian potentially
moving in a kind of neo-fascists
direction and that's where these
universalizing united resistance forces
are very very important and they failed
in Germany and I'm very you know I've
written a lot about fascism and Germany
and so I'm very conscious of this and
its idea of universalizing is partly
related to that concern that unless we
have these universalizing movements that
bring together both the movements and
the political parties and bring them
movements together and bring you know
just coordinate because you know at the
heart of this is the recognition that
global capitalism is a what academics
like used to you know like to call an
intersectional system that is there is a
reflects a system of you know dominant
power hierarchies which are
interconnected race and capitalism are
not the same thing you can have racism
in other economic systems and there can
capitalism potentially without racism
both hard to imagine America but they
are really intertwined like DNA
DNA strands so in you're going to catch
the system you need to recognize and
black feminists like well whole bunch of
them but people who leading black lives
matter now and so for to call themselves
socialists there you're seeing in a lot
of these movements in the environmental
move you're seeing Bill McKibben who was
very insular and sidle and we started
with a lot of his work on three
fifty.org environment but has moved much
more to understanding the connection I
wrote a book called read to green
earlier and he blurred that book because
he was beginning to recognize that you
couldn't deal with climate change unless
you deal with capitalist and Charles I'm
curious and we have we have so much to
get to we actually are starting to sort
of run out of time even in the second
part and and I had a dozen or so
questions we were at we got a really
good answer to one but there's a couple
other things I do want to touch on
you're sort of talking about the sort of
positioning of what the left should have
in American politics and I've been
pretty critical of Democrats who have
run basically on being Republican light
in many ways can you address that a
little bit and whether it's time to
really just be definitively left
absolutely I mean this started with the
Clinton years when the Reagan people
came in they changed they tried to
undermine remember from fifty years
prior to Reagan eight nineteen eighty
you had a New Deal I called regime a new
deal of American politics which operated
under the system of really an effort to
move capitalism as far as possible
towards european-style
Scandinavian style you know justice for
workers and bringing together all kinds
of social justice issues that element
Roosevelt human rights universal idea
immigration so but Reagan knocked that
out and then the Clintons came along and
explicitly said were no longer the
Democratic Party is no longer a party of
the New Deal we're not for big
government were not for Social Welfare
and so forth and they did these very
incremental changes and moved heavily
toward an identity kind of politics
which was stripped of its class
sensibilities and awarenesses this has
gone on and and you know Obama
ironically in some way maintained this
he thought I think he felt he's a
cautious politician he
symbolised you know hope and change but
he really continued the Clinton strategy
of kind of moving away from these
economic justice system shaking kind of
politics toward um water I call it Bush
and Bush lighter but to party we don't
have a Labor Party we don't have a real
progressive party in United States like
there are in Europe so I feel yes to
your question this is a period and
that's why Sanders and you know people
like Elizabeth Warren my senator so far
are so important because they represent
a new energy within the progressive wing
of the Democratic Party a lot of them of
the black caucus the Progressive Caucus
on the party you know indivisible
there's a whole set of new grassroots
younger millennial people who are going
to push the Democratic Party to the left
and this is the moment and you mentioned
David the public opinion supports that
you among Millennials more Millennials
say they are positive toward the idea of
democratic socialism I think they're
thinking about Sanders sort of style
rather and they're negative about
capitalism so if you look at public
opinion polls which I've put into the
book just to punctuate this point there
is enormous public support for these
progressive positions the Democrats can
win by highlighting these issues whether
whether it were they having to do with
you know medical care for all or social
security things which the Republicans
are going to be going after or whether
it's unions minimum wage the role of
money and politics that you know
citizens united the public opinion is
there for the Democratic Party to really
move to the left but the Democratic
Party since Clinton has been funded by
Wall Street and by and the big
Democratic funders who will play an
enormous role in where mainstream
parties go have been retarding that and
they found candidates in the Clintons
and even in Obama who were sort of
reconciled themselves to these
traditional limits of the Democrats
since Clinton and this is the moment for
change for transformative change and you
know we're in a period of emergency
climate change weather nuclear
impossibilities and Iran or Korea
whatever
don't have time to play around and to be
to be incremental about this I mean
incremental all kinds of change are good
but we need a mainstream party that is
going to shake this system up and I
think that's why Sanders who plays you
know is the most popular politician in
America today according to Gallup polls
he's got a 60% approval rating in red
states as well as blue states so the
Democrats can have a 50-state strategy
and win all over the country as long as
they bring this kind of universal
ice-cream message including to the
trumpian working class who is going to
be very disenchanted purely on economic
grounds with Trump's you know policies I
mean they might like his identity
politics that we talked about the
beginning yeah his he's really going to
bring jobs that are jobs that we've
brought to bottom all or whatever they
may bring back few jobs but they're
going to there's going to be no unions
there going to be no regulation no
minimum wage and they're going to be
terrible jobs that most of his followers
are not going to be one of doing a lot
of what we've been talking about from
the book welcome to the revolution
universalizing resistance for social
justice and democracy in perilous times
we've been speaking with the book's
author Charles durbur thanks so much for
talking to us about the book thank you
so much David I really appreciate it